I'm here at Davos 2016 this is my first
time in Davos and I'm really excited to
be here at forums like these where we
have CEOs and we have heads of state
it's really important that privacy be
part of our discussion I study human
factors in security and privacy we're
doing research to understand how
security and privacy impact people and
how to build tools that people can
actually use right now when we talk to
consumers they say yeah I don't
understand online advertising I bought a
pair of shoes yesterday and now today
all the ads I get her for shoes and
that's really creepy I don't understand
how they know that about me we're going
to have more and more devices collecting
data about us from all different kinds
of sources our research suggests that
putting users in control is part of the
solution so at carnegie mellon we're
building a personal privacy assistant
and the idea is that it will run on your
smartphone or your SmartWatch and it
will have a listen in the air for these
privacy policies that these sensors have
and provide you with controls this is
putting the power back to the consumer
you